Transcriber: Gamze YAKUT
Gözden geçirme: Başak Gökdaş
Merhabalar, hepiniz hoş geldiniz.
(Alkış)
Ben de canım memleketim olan
Kayseri’me hoş geldim.
Burada gerçekten bir sürü
tanıdığım insan var
ve onları görmek
şu anda beni çok mutlu etti.
Ben bugün buraya sizlere güzellik ile
ilgili deneyimlerimi anlatmaya geldim.
1987 yılında Kayseri’de, 4 çocuklu bir
ailenin ikinci ve tek sarışın kız çocuğu
olarak dünyaya geldim.
Şimdi başlangıç cümlemi böyle
seçmemde özel bir sebep var.
Çünkü Kayseri'de sarışın çocuk
görmek çok zordur.
Genellikle esmer ve kumral ağırlıklı
bir gen havuzu mevcut.
Eğer sarışın bir çocuk görürseniz de
onun bir Çerkez çocuğu
olduğununu varsayarsınız.
Tabii o sıralarda ben de
benden 5 yaş büyük olan ablam da
henüz bu sosyal kodlamaların
farkında değildik.
Ben zaten küçük bir bebektim.
Ablam da heyecanla kardeşini bekleyen 5
yaşında bir çocuktu ve o güne kadar
gerçekten üzerine titrenilerek büyütülmüş
ve bu harika hayatında kardeşiyle
paylaşmak için can atıyordu.
Tabii o sıralarda doğum yapan
annemi ve beni
yani bebeği görmeye gelen
konu komşu, akrabalarımız
Belki kötü niyetleri olmaksızın ama
kesinlikle düşüncesizce benim ne kadar
beyaz bir çocuk olduğuma, mavi gözlerime,
sarı saçlarıma övgüde bulunarak
″Aaa bu kız kime çekmiş ya?
Hiç ablasına benzemiyor″
diyerek daha ilk günden
ablamı bana düşman ettiler.
Evet efendim böyle oldu.
Daha sonrasında ablamla böyle inişli
çıkışlı bir çocukluk hayatımız oldu.
Ablam beni hep içten içe çok sevse de
bazen bana nedensizce çok eziyet etmiştir.
Ama ben bununla ilgili onu
asla suçlamadım.
Hiçbir zaman da suçlamadım.
Hatta büyüdüğümüzde
bunları konuşarak, hatta bunlarla dalga
geçerek kardeşliğimizin tadını çıkardık.
Yani şu anda aramız gayet iyi,
her şey yolunda.
(Alkış)
Sağ olun.
Tabii o sıralarda bu övgüleri alırken
bunun benim hayatım için daha sonrasında
çok belirleyici bir şey olduğunu tabii
henüz o zaman bebekken ben bilmiyordum.
Ama daha o zamandan ″Övgü ve
güzellik tehlikelidir,
başkalarının seni düşman bellemesine
neden olur.″
inancımın ilk tohumları atılmış oldu.
Tabii ablamla bu süreçler geçtikten
sonra benim okul hayatım başladı.
İlkokul, işte ortaokul, lise, üniversite
hatta daha sonrasında iş hayatımda bile bu
nedensizce düşmanca olan tavırları gördüm
ve bir süre sonra bu tavırları artık o
kadar iyi tanır hale geldim ki gördüğüm
yerde hemen şak diye algılar oldum.
Uzmanlık alanım gibi bir şey oldu.
Tabii o sıralarda tekrar ergenliğime
dönecek olursak, o yılları dönecek olursak
o sıralarda ben de kendini tanımaya,
keşfetmeye çalışan genç bir kızım.
Yani bunu da unutmayın.
Benim de hayata dair bilmediğim
bir sürü şey var.
Öğrenmeye, keşfetmeye çalıştığım
Ben de insanlar tarafından sevilmek,
arkadaşlarım tarafından sevilmek,
olduğum gibi kabul edilmek istiyorum.
Ama böyle düşmanca bir tavır
gördüğüm zaman da çok kafam karışıyor
ve üzülüyorum.
Tabii bir süre sonra
boyum uzadı benim ergenlikte.
Baya bir boy attım, iyice
fenalaştı durum ve ben artık kendimi
saklamanın yollarını aramaya başladım.
Daha böyle içe kapanık, hüzünlü,
arkadaş edinmeyi çok isteyen ama
çekingen biri oldum.
Tabii bu daha sonrasında benim
bedenime de yansıdı.
Daha böyle omuzlarım öne
düşük bir duruşum oldu.
Saçlarımı kısacık kestirdim.
Gözlerim bozuk olmadığı halde annemden
ve babamdan gözlük dilenen bir
genç kıza dönüştüm.
Yani kısacası ″Ugly Betty″
olmak istedim.
Sonra üniversite yıllarımda, son yıllarına
doğru hayatıma oyunculuk girdi.
Ve hiç tahmin etmediğim bir şekilde
bana çok iyi geldi.
Çünkü; kendimi, insanları,
daha doğrusu insanı anlamaya dair
ve araştırmaya dair
bir süreç başladı beynimde.
Ve ben bir farkettim ki
ben başta kendimi anlamıyor
ve kabul etmiyorum.
Bu benim için çok sarsıcı oldu
ve zamanla şunu da anladım ki
başkaları beni tehdit olarak görmesin diye
ben kendimi olabildiğince küçültmüşüm.
Mesela birisi bana ne kadar güzelsin diye
bir iltifatta bulunduğunda
asla teşekkür ederim diyemezdim.
Ya basit bir teşekkürü edemezdim.
Hemen olur bu, sen daha güzelsin,
ay o senin güzel bakışın, ben güzel
değilim aslında, sen öyle sanıyorsun
falan diye böyle resmen o insanın,
o iltifatını da ağzına tıkardım.
Bu tavrım o insanları da çok huzursuz
ederdi ve rahatsız ederdi.
Yani onların asla herhangi bir iltifatta
bulunmasına izin vermezdim.
İşin trajik yanı ben kendime de
hiçbir konuda izin vermezdim.
Hayatı yaşamaya,
en azından kendi huyumun suyumun tadını
çıkarmaya izin vermezdim.
Sonrasında o dönemlerde İstanbul’da artık
yaşamaya ve oyunculuk yapmaya başlamış,
bir yandan oyunculuk eğitimlerine de devam
eden 23-24 yaşlarında genç bir kadın oldum
ve içimden böyle bir isyan koptu.
İçimden bir ses bana dedi ki
″Yeter ya, bırak ya! ″ dedi.
Bırak dedi yani bırak biz de şu hayat
neymiş birazcık yaşayalım dedi.
O dönem yine bir fark ettim ki
benim bu okul yıllarından
düşmanca tavırlar gördüğüm arkadaşlarım,
hatta ablam bile her gün benimle değilken
ben onların hayaletlerini
sırtımda taşıyorum sanki.
Yani onlar artık benim gündelik hayatımın
bir parçası değiller.
Hiçbirini görmüyorum.
Hatta ablam bile benim gündelik
hayatımın bir parçası değil.
Artık onlar benim hayatımda yoklar ama ben
onlarla yaşamaya devam ediyorum
ve buna bir son verme kararı aldım.
Dedim ki ben de kendime
istediğim gibi özgürce yaşayacağım.
Çünkü özümde aslında böyle
ön planda olmayı seven,
insanlarla sohbet etmeyi seven
doğal biriyimdir
ve bunu baskılamama kararı aldım.
Mesela birisi bana iltifat ettiğinde
gayet sevinçle ve gülümseyerek
teşekkür etmeye başladım.
Hatta o dönem dedim ki kendi kendime
eğer birisi, daha beni gördüğünde
hiç merhaba bile demeden,
tanımadan bir tehdit olarak
görüyorsa bu onun sorunudur dedim
ve kendimi özgür bırakma kararı aldım.
İlk defa kendime topuklu
bir ayakkabı aldım.
Çünkü boyum uzun olduğu için asla topuklu
giymemem gerektiğini düşünürdüm nedense.
Saçlarımı uzattım ve içimden
geldiği gibi herkesle sosyalleştim.
Bakın tam bu kısımda çok
enteresan bir şey var
aslında onu paylaşmak
istiyorum sizlerle bugün.
Burada çok enteresan bir tavır var.
Burada anlatmaya çalıştığım, altını
çizmeye çalıştığım şey güzellik değil.
Sizler de bir düşünün şimdi hayatınızda
mutlaka sizin de tanıdığınız,
kendisini olduğu gibi
iyisiyle kötüsüyle kabul eden,
kendi doğallığını yaşayan
herhangi birini gördüğümüzde,
herhangi öyle birinin yanına gittiğimizde
bize de bir sevinç ve rahatlama gelir.
Şöyle bir örnek daha vereyim.
Çünkü biz o insanları yanına
gittiğimizde bir sevinç
ve rahatlama hissederiz.
Onlarla sohbet etmek, konuşmak,
takılmak isteriz.
Çünkü o insanlar doğaldır.
Mesela herhangi bir ormanda,
parkta gezdiğinizde
sizlerin de bedenlerinizde ve ruhunuzda
bir rahatlama ve huzur hissettiyseniz eğer
bu buna benzer bir his.
O dönem bunları düşünürken bir yerde
şöyle bir cümleye denk geldim
ve bu beni  çok etkiledi.
Orada diyor ki.
Bu arada ablamla benim çok güzel
bir fotoğrafımız vardı
onu açabilir miyiz?
Onu size göstermeyi unuttum,
konuşmaya daldım.
Bakın efendim, bu ablamla ben.
Ablacığım.
(Alkış)
Şimdi o okuduğum cümlede şöyle
bir şeyden bahsediyor.
Bizler doğaya gittiğimizde, doğada vakit
geçirdiğimizde
insanlar yani doğada vakit geçirdiklerinde
kendilerini çok huzurlu hissederlermiş.
Çünkü doğa onları takmazmış.
O kendi akışında akmaya,
doğallığında akmaya devam edermiş.
Yani doğaya gittiğimiz zaman bizlerin de
bedenlerinde ve zihinlerinde
bir rahatlama olurmuş.
Tıpkı kendi doğalını kabul eden, kendini
olduğu gibi kabul eden
insanların yanında hissettiğimizdeki gibi.
O yüzden son cümlelerimi şu şekilde
özetlemek istiyorum.
Benim bütün bu deneyimlerimden
çıkardığım sonuç şu oldu.
Bugün insanın kendisine destek vermesinin,
kendisine şefkatle yaklaşmasının
ve doğalında olduğu kişiyi olduğu gibi
kabul edip onu yeşertmesinin
bu dünyada yapılabilecek
en büyük iyilik olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Kendinizi onurlandırın, onunla ilgilenin
ve asla yalnız bırakmayın.
(Alkış)
Çünkü;
hiç düşündünüz mü bilmiyorum ama
onun sizden başka kimsesi yok.
Teşekkür ederim.